et avec nous la Strip de Vilaine bonjour
Astrid merci
d'être là directeur adjo de la rédaction
du Figaro Alex nous a rejoint et on va
parler évidemment de la locution
d'Emmanuel Macron que peut dire le chef
de l'État comment renouer le lien avec
les Français et as encore possible vous
nous le direz et puis on verra si la
sortie de crise passe par un accord avec
les républicains l'idée fait son chemin
dans le parti de droite à un accord de
gouvernement est-il désormais
inéluctable vous nous direz ce que vous
en pensez c'est à suivre tout de suite
dans ce club et on commence par cette
allocution d'Emmanuel Macron le chef de
l'État qui va donc prendre la parole ce
soir à 20h objectif apaiser la colère
des Français après la promulgation
rapide de la réforme des retraites alors
qu'attendent les oppositions de cette
allocution on va ça avec Quentin calmer
avec cette adresse aux Français à 20h
depuis l'Élysée le chef de l'État
devrait tenter de fixer un cap pour la
suite du quinquennat mais dans
l'opposition hier on était très
sceptique sur le message de ce soir
enchaînement qu'est-ce qui va se passer
mais il va rien se passer je vous le dis
vous attendez rien de cette option si le
président de la République nous dit
qu'il a compris ça fait 25 fois qu'il
nous dit qu'il a compris et derrière il
n'y a jamais le moindre changement et
pendant ce temps-là la colère continue à
gronder dans l'esprit de tous la crise
liée à la réforme des retraites hors de
question de tourner la page pour les
oppositions après la promulgation
express de la loi au Journal officiel je
crois que le président a tout fait pour
que l'on attend de rien du tout de son
allocution il a tout fait pour que le
lien soit rompu il est face à un pays
qu'il a lui-même fracturé
et avec son allocution le chef de l'État
devrait entrer dans une logique
d'apaisement a dit le porte-parole du
gouvernement mais pour la chef de fil du
rassemblement national la cassure avec
l'opinion est actée
les Français les uns contre les autres à
brutaliser le peuple français en réalité
à gouverné contre le peuple français il
s'en fait presque une gloire et je pense
que la manière dont il a promulgué avec
une rapidité tout à fait inhabituelle et
assez puéril il faut bien le dire cette
réforme des retraites démontre qu'il est
encore dans un état d'esprit de
provocation prochaine étape pour le chef
de l'État après son discours de ce soir
un déplacement dans les départements
pour tenter de renouer avec les Français
et ce en milieu de semaine
on va parler avec vous de cette
allocution Astrid
est allocution peut être utile que peut
dire le chef de l'État est-ce qu'il peut
vraiment renouer le lien
si on s'en réfère à la dernière
intervention de Emmanuel Macron
c'est-à-dire ce fameux 13h de France 2
TF1 il y a à peu près un mois moi j'ai
le sentiment qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup
fait bouger les lignes presque même au
contraire elle a remobilisé d'une
certaine manière les manifestants
j'ajoute que je trouve que le
l'utilisation d'une allocution à 20h qui
est un moment très solennelle
enfin fait qu'on attend quelque chose
d'important donc il faut absolument pas
que ce soit une intervention pour rien
je pense moi ça me rappelle aussi un
petit peu ses vœux qui avait fait un peu
l'effet d'un coup d'épée dans l'eau les
vœux du du 31 décembre donc on sent en
fait qu'il tâtonne je trouve au sommet
de l'État sur comment résoudre cette
crise parce que si c'est juste pour nous
dire refixer le cap ce qu'il était déjà
censé avoir fait là il y a un mois au
trésor d'ailleurs il l'a rappelé au
moment où Elisabeth borne a dit il faut
apaiser les choses etc il a dit le cap a
déjà été fixé donc si c'est pour ce
qu'on entend un petit peu alors déjà
refixer le cap ça veut dire qu'il a été
déjà très mal fixé si c'est pour
simplement parler des mesures qui ont
été censurées par le Conseil
constitutionnel le CDI senior je suis
pas sûr que les Français attendent ça
parce que même avant la censure il n'en
voulait toujours pas de cette réforme
même avec ces quelques avancées là donc
moi je crois qu'il faut qu'il parle
d'écologie par exemple il y a quand même
un feu de forêt important aujourd'hui
dans les Pyrénées-Orientales ou et
Christophe Béchu le ministre de
l'écologie il est pas là c'est très rare
qu'un feu comme ça se produise avant
même l'été on est on est qu'au mois
d'avril je crois qu'il faut qu'il parle
des institutions c'est un sujet qu'il
avait en tête au début de son deuxième
quinquennat qui l'a complètement mis de
côté alors que on voit que c'est aussi
une crise démocratique qui se joue et
qu'il parle des salaires donc ça
m'étonnerait la réforme des retraites ça
m'étonnerait qu'il fasse ça mais moi je
me dis si il faut prendre un peu de
hauteur et aller un peu plus loin que
les simples voilà quelques semaines qui
viennent de s'écouler il doit tourner la
page de la réforme de notre il peut
tourner la page
c'est pas lui qui va tourner la page
c'est les Français est-ce que les
Français sont disposés à tourner la page
donc c'est compliqué pour lui il va
avoir deux il y a deux rôles à mon avis
dans cette dans cette intervention le
premier c'est d'expliquer quand même
qu'il y a le droit pour lui qu'il y a
l'égalité et revenir quand même sur le
vote pourquoi il a
effectivement
promulgué aussi rapidement le texte
peut-être que il faut qu'il s'explique
là-dessus
et puis
après
il a un petit côté provocateur mais en
plus bon généralement les les lois sont
promulguées très très rapidement donc
c'est pas très étonnant et puis il faut
qu'il soit d'accord avec Astrid il faut
qu'il trouve quelque chose de nouveau il
faut vraiment qu'il imprime de sa de sa
de la nouveauté cette intervention parce
que sinon on va encore dire que c'est
une intervention pour rien
pour nous endormir d'une certaine façon
donc là il faut qu'il trouve quelque
chose effectivement il y a trois pistes
il y a
la piste du pouvoir d'achat mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la piste du
pouvoir d'achat parce que l'État est
déjà extrêmement dépensier on a une
dette de l'ordre de 3000 milliards de de
d'euros
ça me paraît assez compliqué ça il y a
une deuxième piste qui sont les services
publics et à mon avis ça il aurait
intérêt à intervenir là-dessus c'est une
promesse qui était née du covid et une
promesse qui n'a jamais été tenue c'est
à dire que il faut restaurer tout le
monde en est conscient l'hôpital l'école
certains services publics qui sont
aujourd'hui dans des états compliqués et
puis la troisième effectivement la
feuille de route peut être une feuille
de route écologique c'est pas simple non
plus parce que
c'est nécessairement dépensier aussi
et puis on voit très bien que tout le
monde est pour mais chez le voisin papa
pour soi-même donc ça va être c'est
compliqué et l'écologie c'est aussi les
mobilités c'est aussi les déplacements
et on sait que dès qu'on touche à ça ben
c'est assez explosif d'une certaine
façon donc il va falloir qu'il trouve
quelque chose de nouveau parler des
institutions pourquoi pas mais le
problème si vous voulez c'est que parler
des institutions les Français faut pas
non plus les ils sont pas du quoi
si c'est pour encore ouvrir une énième
commission
et puis dire voilà on va faire telle
chose ou telle chose ça je pense que les
Français sont pas dupe et que ça sera
pas suffisant sachant qu'on a toujours
pas de nouvelles de la commission
transpartisane sur les institutions qui
auraient dû être ouvertes est-ce que
donc vous êtes d'accord tous les deux
pour dire qu'il doit se projeter au-delà
de la réforme des retraites est-ce que
quand même il doit revenir sur cette
réforme des retraites est-ce qu'il doit
s'expliquer à nouveau où est-ce que sur
ce sujet désormais toute parole de sa
part je pense qu'il va quand même en
dire un mot parce que c'est quand même
le sujet l'éléphant dans la pièce ça
serait quand même bizarre de pas du tout
en parler surtout qu'il est attendu
là-dessus et que lui-même en fait mais
aussi en scène cette allocution pour
clore la séquence c'est ce qu'on
comprend moi je crois qu'il a accéléré
quand même dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi pour aller vite c'est ce que
disent c'est ministre son entourage en
disant nous voilà maintenant c'est
derrière nous ils essayent de dire que
c'est derrière nous mais j'ai vu moi des
appels sur les réseaux sociaux d'attaque
de la France insoumise à vous savez
faire un concert de casseroles devant
les mairies ou au balcon comme au moment
du covid à 20h pour justement ne pas
l'écouter je ne sais pas quelle va être
l'ampleur de cette mobilisation mais si
c'est le cas c'est un signal à mon avis
plus que faible sur la défiance et la
crise qui ne serait pas seulement
sociale politique démocratique mais qui
serait qui le viserait lui directement
parce que vous imaginez l'image même à
l'international d'un président de la
République plus au sommet de l'État qui
fait une allocution même pas une interne
une allocution depuis l'Élysée qui n'est
pas entendu par son peuple qui refuse de
l'écouter je crois qu'on rentre dans une
autre dimension si c'est ça qui arrive
le problème aujourd'hui qui a il y a une
espèce de divorce entre le président et
l'opinion publique si on en croit les
sondages et ce qui est sûr si vous
voulez c'est que ça touche même sa
personne sa façon d'être sa façon d'être
et de gouverner de parler de de
d'agir qui est sans doute considérée un
peu trop arrogante un peu trop il
mélange d'arrogance d'indifférence de
distance qui n'est pas du tout apprécié
les Français et qui je dirais encore qui
qui encore davantage souligné parce
qu'il est jeune parce que c'est un homme
qui est évidemment n'a pas l'expérience
de quelqu'un de plus âgé et donc c'est
un reproche qui lui offert il y a
presque aussi un reproche en un procès
angélisme qui lui est fait alors vous me
direz tous les présidents de la
République sous la 5e ont été ont connu
leur période de détestation on avec
Sarkozy on l'a vu à l'école land on l'a
aussi un peu vu avec les prédécesseurs
c'était plus c'était un peu différent
parce qu'on était dans des scepts avec
des hommes peut-être un peu plus
blindés quoi qui était plus âgé quoi que
Giscard d'Estaing était quand même très
jeune mais je trouve que chez Emmanuel
Macron c'est une dimension qui est très
forte qui qui relève de l'irrationnel
c'est complètement irrationnel est-ce
qu'il doit aussi tendre la main au
syndicat est-ce qu'il peut tendre la
main au syndicat en français
non mais je sais pas parce que je pense
que les français se sentent aussi
finalement c'est paradoxal parce que peu
de gens sont syndiqués mais ce sont
aussi représentés par l'Inter syndical
dans ce dans ce combat là et on voit
bien que là il a déjà eu un refus en
fait puisqu'il a maintenu cette
invitation pour mardi donc le lendemain
et que on lui a dit non je on ne viendra
pas donc ça va être c'est compliqué de
parler de ça alors qu'il s'est un peu
pris un refuge je pense mais peut-être
qu'il va refaire un appel au syndicat
pour revenir à la table pour parler
d'autre chose mais ce serait un peu à
contretemps aussi puisque pour l'instant
c'est non donc moi je suis assez
d'accord avec qui je pense plutôt parler
aux Français qu'au syndicats c'est c'est
pas le lieu c'est pas le moment
il faut quand même faire aussi le bilan
de cette histoire et syndicat en une
part de responsabilité dans le bazar
qu'il y a dans notre pays je dirais les
syndicats c'est qui les syndicats il
représente quoi
au nom de qui parle-t-il moi je viens
qu'on fasse de Monsieur berger le
nouveau président de la République mais
faut arrêter quoi et les médias
ont une part de responsabilité là-dedans
enfin je veux dire monsieur berger c'est
Monsieur berger comme Madame Binet
madame Binet quoi voilà mais ils sont
dans la rue oui mais un million de gens
dans la rue sur 38 sur 30 millions
d'actifs c'est c'est moi je pense que le
malaise du pays c'est tous ceux qui
justement ne se sentent pas entendu qui
sont ni pour le désordre qui a été créé
parce que quand même on a atteint des
des des
sommets de des rationnels et puis
ces gens là c'est eux qui font l'opinion
à mon avis qui font le vote et à mon
avis c'est c'est à eux qui doivent
s'adresser de départ
vendredi le jour du de la des décisions
du Conseil constitutionnel ils ont quand
même demandé officiellement à Emmanuel
Macron de ne pas promulguer la loi et
lui il a fait dans la nuit comme ça on
sait tous se réveiller avec donc je
pense qu'il y a une femme là ça devient
une crispation qui est voilà il se sent
même plus face à face ils sont deux ados
moi je voilà j'utilise toujours l'image
du bras de fer c'est un bras de fer ça
se tend et qui va l'en porter là où je
mettrai quand même une nuance et je
pense que en effet les syndicats
représentent pas tout le pays mais
beaucoup beaucoup de gens dans le pays
ne veulent pas de cette réforme et là
les derniers sondages après la
promulgation du texte disent que 65% des
Français veulent que la mobilisation se
poursuivent c'est à dire que on peut
aussi être en soutien j'allais dire sans
participation
soutenir les grévistes et les
manifestations ce qui est quand même
rare dans ce pays souvent ça on a plutôt
des vous avez vu on a eu beaucoup de
reportages de de journalistes qui
cherchait à des gens énervés par la
grève on en trouvait pas enfin les gens
étaient là non non au contraire
continuaient je vois quand même des
chercheurs éminents des historiens des
nous dire qu'on est dans une situation
pré révolutionnaire moi je n'en sais
rien mais j'écoute quand même tout ce
genre de choses donc je sais pas si
c'est une manifestation classique on
avait les gilets jaunies à 4 ans il faut
quand même être à mon avis ne pas faire
d'erreur tactiques là quand on est au
sommet de l'État parce que le pays est
très très tendu
la France danse sur un volcan hein mais
non et pour répondre à la crise
politique Emmanuel Macron va-t-il tendre
la main aux républicain ce soir Alex
quels sont les options qui s'offrent au
parti de droite alors pour les
républicains on peut préciser que c'est
aussi une crise politique ça allait pour
Emmanuel Macron mais également pour la
droite qui sort très divisé de cette
séquence de la réforme des retraites
puisque les républicains c'était mis
d'accord avec le gouvernement pour voter
ce texte en échange de quelques
améliorations et au final il y a quand
même eu 19 députés les républicains qui
ont voté la censure du gouvernement
alors que faire pour les LR qui sont
très affaiblis politiquement la première
option c'est de former une grande
coalition de gouvernement avec la
majorité présidentielle un remaniement
profond du gouvernement en premier
ministre de droite donner une nouvelle
direction au quinquennat alors c'est
quand même une option qui est pour le
moment assez peu probable seulement
trois députés LR l'ont appelé de leurs
vœux la semaine dernière dans une
tribune dans Le Figaro et notamment le
député Philippe juin c'est l'option qui
est défendu par l'ancien président
Nicolas Sarkozy et bien cette coalition
on en a encore loin et si le sénateur
les républicains Roger carochi qui était
sur ce plateau ce matin pour avoir un
accord de gouvernement il faut être deux
est-ce que le Président de la République
mettre des horloges nous a proposé un
accord de gouvernement non on nous
demande chaque fois à nous est-ce que
vous êtes pour un accord de gouvernement
mais qui nous l'a proposé à part les
journalistes si le président disait
éventuellement coalition cohabitation
cohabitation avec des parties qui sont
dans la majorité ou en dehors de la
majorité sur un projet sur des thèmes
précis immigration sécurité loi travail
peut-être qu'on pourrait commencer à
imaginer discuter
alors voilà sans forcément faire partie
de la même majorité et bien la seconde
option c'est de se mettre d'accord sur
quelques réformes à mener dans les
années à venir une forme de
co-construction de contrat cela donnera
un peu de visibilité sur le quinquennat
au gouvernement et un peu plus de
crédibilité au républicains et cette
idée elle est en train de germer en
coulisse chez les républicains par
exemple chez Éric sotti qui s'est sentie
très trahi par Laurent Wauquiez et son
silence pendant la réforme des retraites
les sénateurs LR aussi veulent avoir un
esprit de responsabilité pendant cette
période et même chez les députés les
républicains frondeurs qui ont voté la
censure et bien ils sont quand même
favorables à la co-construction et
écouter Yann Boucard qui était sur notre
plateau vendredi on se mette au travail
sur quelques lois sur des sujets
régaliens je pense à la justice je pense
à la police je pense à l'éducation
nationale ou à la santé qui est la
préoccupation principale des Français
oui moi je j'appelle au travail au
compte construction sur certains sujets
majeurs mais de manière transparente pas
dans les coulisses pas par manière
détournée on la prend dans la presse
voilà une co-construction transparente
et puis la troisième option c'est le
statu quo c'est à dire se prononcer sur
chaque texte que va présenter le
gouvernement alors ça ne va pas
forcément redonner un cap au pays les
républicains qui pourraient aussi faire
tout simplement un cavalier seul et
proposer leur propre texte leur propre
agenda parlementaires c'est ce qu'ils
veulent faire sur l'immigration
puisqu'on le rappelle le projet de loi
immigration du gouvernement a été
reporté pour ne pas braquer un peu plus
le pays et dans le mois à venir et bien
les parlementaires LR vont déposer un
texte sur l'immigration un texte qui
sera ferme et leur objectif et bien
c'est de montrer les faiblesses
d'Emmanuel Macron dans ce domaine donc
voilà pour la palette d'options
politiques qui se présente au LR
laquelle vous paraît la plus probable la
troisième
probablement les LR sont divisés
eux-mêmes et puis je vois pas par
exemple alors je pense pas que ce soit
le président de la République dise voilà
je propose un contrat de gouvernement à
LR je pense que ça va être compliqué les
LR sont pas tous quand même sur la même
longueur d'onde entre eux et je pense
que la troisième solution et celle qui
paraît la plus la plus jouable et la
plus ouverte d'une certaine façon
c'est-à-dire faire du cas par cas et
puis accepter c'est ce qui va
probablement être au centre de la
négociation des propositions de loi
faites de de parler LR c'est une façon
d'acheter leur leur complicité et
leur voix à mon avis
je doute que il se lance dans un
remaniement ministériel avec un
changement de Premier ministre
et que que dans ce cadre là il nomme un
républicain à Matignon je crois pas
qu'on en soit là donc je pense que ça va
être vraiment assez timide et
expérimental
oui sauf que en fait ça c'est ce qui se
passe depuis le début et je pense que la
réforme des retraites c'est quand même
un stigmate quand même pour ces deux
parties Renaissance et LR parce que il y
a eu quand même un problème de
communication à minima de politique
sûrement ils se sont fait avoir en fait
une naissance parallèles qui avait dit
oui donnez-nous tout ça et ils avaient
de borne quand même qui faisait des une
dans la presse pour dire ça c'est ok les
carrières longues etc il y a beaucoup
cédé beaucoup d'argent d'ailleurs aux
républicain tout ça pour ne pas avoir
leur voix au final donc moi je suis pas
sûr qu'il puisse vraiment compter sur un
parti qui est quand même un petit peu
dans les choux quand même au point de
vue national et qui en effet compte
autant de Line politique qu'il y a de
députés ou de sénateurs on dirait
moi j'avais proposé la cohabitation
choisie il y a quelques semaines ça veut
dire en fait c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
se met lui-même dans un une posture de
cohabitation sans même de vote en disant
prenez les clés du camion allez-y faites
ce que vous voulez vous avez Matignon je
pense que c'était jouable il y a
quelques temps que aujourd'hui je suis
plus sûre parce qu'en fait la situation
s'est tellement tendue qu'on a
l'impression que les oppositions n'ont
aucune envie en réalité de prendre une
part de responsabilité dans la crise
actuelle et n'ont aucune envie d'être
d'une manière ou d'une autre responsable
ou co-responsable du bilan d'Emmanuel
Macron qui on a la sensation va quand
même dans le mur je m'étonne d'ailleurs
que Emmanuel Macron n'arrive pas à
sortir par le haut de cette crise avec
avec d'autres projets je pense par
exemple à la culture il y a rien sur la
culture qui est fait depuis 6 ans rien
il y a rien qui est lancé pour marquer
sa trace dans l'histoire Emmanuel Macron
dans 4 ans il peut plus représenter
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
les Jeux Olympiques non mais je sais pas
oui mais je parle de culture de
monuments pour Chirac de la pyramide du
Louvre pour Mitterrand un peu de hauteur
voyez d'esprit plutôt que d'être comme
ça dans la tambouille de 2 ou 3
milliards d'euros donc moi je pense que
la enfin ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il va
se tourner vers la droite ça c'est
évident parce que il c'est ce qui fait
depuis le démarrage et que mais il a le
droit de son côté je trouve a aussi une
forme de responsabilité face à ses
électeurs parce que pardon mais la
réforme de retraite c'est c'est quand
même ce qu'attendre les lecteurs
normalement les lecteurs de droite et
l'immigration c'est pareil et la plupart
des mesures économiques ou sociales que
que propose Emmanuel Macron elles sont
en accord avec l'ADN des républicains
donc comment vont-ils ensuite justifier
qu'il ne vote pas des textes qui vont
dans le bon sens c'est peut-être
là-dessus aussi que que mise Elisabeth
borne le gouvernement ça et le fait que
dont les sondages ce ne sont des
sondages mais Laurent Wauquiez il est à
5%, est-ce que les LR vont avoir
d'autres choix que de finir par accepter
un accord avec le gouvernement non c'est
sûr qu'ils sont très très mal les
républicains ils sont pas dans une bonne
posture
je pense que les élections européennes
ne vont pas non plus les aider parce que
ils risquent fort de faire un score qui
soit pas à la hauteur de leurs ambitions
et je pense que effectivement pardon
qui était déjà une désillusion terrible
mais alors pour que moi je suis assez
d'accord avec Astrid mais je pense que
il y a un pari qui est qui est fait sur
les Jeux Olympiques je pense que les
Jeux Olympiques avec cette série mini
d'ouverture qui ne ressemblera à aucune
autre qui est à haut risque très haut
risque sécuritaire
si elle est réussie ça sera
effectivement un moment exceptionnel sur
6 km
presque l'équivalent de la construction
d'un monument ou enfin ça ça sera
l'équivalent et si là il faut pas qu'il
se souple les Jeux Olympiques ça peut
être et moi je pense qu'il mise beaucoup
là-dessus aux Jeux Olympiques avec
Notre-Dame aussi c'est des symboles tout
ça évidemment ça va pas améliorer la vie
des gens mais ce sont des symboles qui
disent quelque chose de la grandeur de
la France parce qu'il y a ça aussi j'ai
beaucoup de Français c'est le sentiment
que la France est en voie de
déclassement et donc c'est mesures là où
ces événements là peuvent rehausser un
petit peu le niveau mais pour conclure
Astrid rapidement il peut tenir
juste c'est dans un peu moins de 500
jours ça paraît très très loin je suis
dans une dans une période où je n'arrive
pas à prédire le lendemain donc je suis
désolé c'est toujours compliqué
en revanche ce qui est vrai c'est que si
on prend juste des précédents c'est plus
facile d'analyser le passé il y a quand
même eu ce scandale du Stade de France
en rappelons-nous au final de la ligue
des champions on a des forces de l'ordre
dans un état d'épuisement lunaire on a
des transports qui vont très très mal en
Île-de-France on le sait nous qui
habitons là je sais pas comment ça va se
passer avec des tas de gens qui vont
arriver du monde entier des logements
qui vont mal on a encore une explosion à
Marseille le pays moi je trouve que pour
l'instant il est pas prêt alors on nous
dit c'est prêt c'est prêt moi je sais
pas comment ils vont faire pour être
prêt mais on verra et on suivra tout ça
allez on a 500 jours pour voir ça on
reparle de cette allocution d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est à la une de vos quotidien
région de ce matin
[Musique]
Alex la locution d'Emmanuel Macron fait
la Une de plusieurs de nos quotidiens
régionaux et oui certains journaux sont
plus critiques que d'autres Macron prêt
à avancer comme si de rien n'était
estime le journal La Charente Libre un
président qui n'a rien compris pour le
journal La Marseillaise pour le Progrès
de Lyon Emmanuel Macron va tenter ce
soir de reprendre la main avec cette
allocution et une question se pose elle
a une du journal L'Alsace comment
peut-il se relancer après cette séance
cette séquence compliquée de la réforme
des retraites alors le président va
tenter de refixer de repréciser un cap
autour notamment du pouvoir d'achat de
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et de l'industrie verte l'industrie des
carbonées mais hors de question pour les
syndicats en face de tourner la page de
cette opposition à la réforme des
retraites il défileront Unis le 1er mai
prochain avec la volonté de faire
descendre dans la rue le plus de monde
possible la guerre en Ukraine à la une
du Courrier Picard et on apprend que
certains soldats Ukrainiens blessés sont
soignés à Amiens et oui les gueules
cassées comme on les appelle sont
soignés pour certaines d'entre elles au
service de chirurgie max spatiale du CHU
d'Amiens actuellement il y a trois
soldats Ukrainiens qui sont et notamment
un soldat qui a été défiguré par un obus
anti-char russe il a été transporté en
voiture privée à l'hôpital d'Amiens qui
est reconnu pour ce domaine de chirurgie
alors pour l'instant va d'Islam ce
soldat ne peut pas parler ne voit pas
encore mais il répond par le geste et il
est accompagné par sa famille qui a fait
le voyage jusqu'en Picardie donc de
longs mois de chirurgie latente de
Nice-Matin les Français ne sont plus
attirés par le CDI le CDI c'était le
Graal aujourd'hui dans le monde du
travail mais il ne fait plus du tout
l'unanimité selon l'Apec l'association
pour l'emploi des cadres et bien 57% des
cadres en entreprise se distraient à
quitter leur poste pour d'autres formes
d'emplois et notamment la
micro-entreprise qui est synonyme de
plus d'autonomie de plus de liberté
autre chiffre seulement à 6% des
Français se sentent engagés dans leur
travail ils sont davantage attirés par
l'objectif de bien-être et de qualité de
vie plutôt que par la sécurité
économique on finit par la Une de La
Voix du Nord qui est consacrée ou à 36e
rencontres internationale du cerf-volant
à Berck avec au programme du ciel bleu
du vent et des cerfs-volants 489
cervelistes de 24 nationalités ce sont
données rendez-vous à Berck ils viennent
à des cinq continents et cela permet de
confronter les différentes cultures du
cerf-volant parce que en Occident c'est
un jeu chez les Indonésiens c'est un
objet sacré qui nous relie aux dieux et
au Guatemala c'est un peu moins drôle
c'est un objet qui a une vocation
funéraire donc voilà c'est très
intéressant ce festival international du
cerf-volant
[Musique]
vous avez rendez-vous ton sens public
très bonne journée à demain
[Musique]